dan Graziano who covers the NFL for the
mothership joins us the National NFL
insider get the official title there for
you damn the Julian Edelman defense is
what well my understanding on Edelman is
that the appeal rests on a couple things
one as has been reported earlier that
they didn't currently identify what the
substance was and then apparently there
was some sort of mishandling of the
information whether it was the
documentation or the delivery of the
information regarding this positive test
to the NFL something got messed up there
and so those two things as I understand
it are the two key prongs of the defense
on that appeal hearing it's being held
today okay but why don't they know what
the substance is like is it this I don't
know like this great mystery like we've
we've never seen this substance before
we have no idea what it is right well I
mean look there are there are drug tests
that that are that are designed to
identify certain types of substances and
it's not out of the question I don't
think that you could stumble on one that
the test is not built to figure out I
don't want to get into speculation on
what kind of curl I mean I'm not a I
don't know how scientists like I don't
know from you know from from how drug
tests work but my understanding is that
this one stoned to the test whatever
that was whether it's something that the
test is designed to test for or whether
it's something that that they just don't
know what it is it's a sort of a
previously unheard of thing I don't
really know but there are so that
there's some murkiness to this whole
thing the key thing to understand those
and the this isn't a part of the process
we usually get to see we don't usually
hear about that the suspension until
after the appeal is hurt this got
reported by Elliot and Adam Schefter a
few weeks ago and that's the only reason
that we really are you know we have
these details because you know what we
got we found out about the suspension
but you're older than we usually do and
quite frankly are supposed to do we care
if these guys transpose data for
steroids well I do I'm a dinosaur
you know I was a baseball writer 14
years still have a Hall of Fame but I
don't go for the guys I think that's me
I understand that that's that's sort of
a saving almost outdated idea but
I mean I to me if I'm paying money to to
watch a game if I appear parked my car
and I'm paying what it costs these games
I would I would like to see an honest
game so yeah I mean I personally think
that that it's important to find out who
is who student who is not but that's me
what if Amal Minh just came out and said
well I I just feel like you know
baseball is a little bit different than
football that that we sort of identified
like we would be doing steroids or HGH
if we played in the NFL like our mind
says man I can't blame you I would do it
too considering what happens to your
body
hey Edelman is coming back from an
injury at his age and you know he took
that took a shortcut here I don't know
if he just came out and did like Andy
Pettitte and said look I took it I was
just trying to help my team and come
back and that we would we moved on from
Andy Pettitte pretty quickly
so I don't know Pettitte actually found
each of us in spring training next year
and like a personally apologized
everybody that covered the team like you
know so when people are authentic like
that it definitely helps but that
doesn't mean I think his rules are in
place for whatever reason so if the NFL
thought was okay to use these drugs and
then they wouldn't test for right did
Clemens apologize to any of the beat
writers dude come on why why is it that
he just won't and minute I don't know I
guess it's possible but it certainly
seems like that there's plenty of
evidence so I think he's always
specially is one of these guys because
you know if I say it loud enough and
then it'll be true right yeah you just
keep you just keep reminding yourself
and then all of a sudden you know you
believe it and look at oj oj oj just
kept telling himself the same story and
then he started to believe it so not
surprised
dan Graziano ESPN national NFL insider
the information so you had the security
breach with Edelman we've seen that with
Jameis Winston as well the NFL has not
made you know had any statement here on
his suspension but now it's possibly
three games how do we get two possibly
three games down
well Adam reported last week was that
the NFL's planning on very game
suspension but it still could go up or
down depending on other factors what my
understanding on Winston is that the
thing is not yet settled that obviously
three games is a possibility but I also
think it's still possible it could
compete fewer it could be I mean if it's
if it's violence against the woman then
the precedent right now says six so if
it's going to be you know something less
than six then I think the league has to
be prepared to explain why and that's an
awfully awkward positions known to be in
so I think there's a lot going on there
I still think there's something going on
there between the accuser and Winston
that could result in some sort of legal
action there and I I don't know whether
it's a matter of the league wanting to
see what happens with that or them
wanting to see what the league does so
there's a lot of I think voices yet to
be heard on that matter if you're the
Buccaneers would you move on from Jameis
Winston well what grounds that you can't
rely on him that he's been he represents
something you'll want to represent like
what I mean this is an incident and
again I think let's not let's make sure
we're not trying to minimize it or not
there's an incident from two-and-a-half
years ago did he keep it from you is
that that affect your your trust in him
I just can't have him in second he
didn't already know you know yeah I
can't have him is the face of the
franchise that's like I just I I don't
think he's they already made that
decision when he came out of college
with really unfortunately shady stuff
attached to him they already made the
decisions that they were okay with that
this is one more thing and it's similar
to some you know to something else we
had heard about him previous and you
know if I were the Bucs what I have
taken Mariota instead probably but they
made their peace with Winston and and
that's you know so the extent to which
it's it's still okay I mean obviously
this is my ownership
there's ownership get to the point where
they're cichlid it's a weird situation
for him contract was twenty point nine
million
here but it's not guaranteed except
against injury until March 13th so they
could cut and healthy if they decide to
so you know six games if it ends up
being a 16 suspension of organ
suspension whatever and you know and
something else comes out doesn't play
well I mean that that's all of a sudden
gets called into question yeah it just
feels like there would be you know
double secret probation zero-tolerance
coming you know into the NFL after what
happened in college and yeah but he's
not great the ratio of trouble to
performance you know it does it's not in
his favor and that that would be that's
the that would be the real concern I
have with him every NFL team and again
let's not let's not minimize what he's
accused of or not but when we talk about
strictly from a football decision
perspective every NFL team if it's
confronting the issue of do we move on
from our quarterback has to answer the
question if so then what and that's a
terrifying question for most NFL teams
and and it keeps a lot of quarterbacks
report oh one final thing and you know
it should be mentioned you cover the NFL
for ESPN but you used to be a baseball
beat writer covering the Yankees I had
this idea for the homerun Derby
what if we did just we totaled up the
feet
you hit a home like the distance per
homerun not the number because you know
there are times when guys have hit you
know what Hamilton did you know where
you're hitting 25 and then the guy
you're competing with to you know move
on to the next round hits 9 what if I
just did we're doing total feat because
it's all about how far we're hitting
homeruns so we just count them all
anyway
no I didn't handle this 25 help him in
the next round
[Music]
first of all tell me how great my idea
is though I mean it's fine
I I think it's it's one of those things
where it's changed the rules every
single year who would care right it's
just some goofy contest and it's fun and
people will tune in and watch it because
it's fun but I don't think you're going
to have a whole big problem with people
ranting raining so welcome this isn't
fair because it was different rules last
year and how can you confirm a this
isn't like you know
real records so I mean I would try
something different every single year I
have one year registed teachers right
and have like hitting pitchers I would
love to do that but I wanted to do this
with the three-point shooting contest
where I had an NBA legend and a current
NBA player so Dell curry and his son
would go against each other
Steve Kerr could compete in it with klay
Thompson or you know klay Thompson and
his dad could be in it but make it fun
and what if I did like a Hall of Famer
and then I did a current guy like you
got to draft and you could you could
pick guys and they could be like Mike
Schmidt's in the home run derby and
George Brett's in the home run derby I
don't know I I got a lot of spare time
like my hands I got a lot of spare time
on my hands damn good to talk to you
good to see a couple of weeks ago and
hopefully talk to you soon all right
Thank You him Benghazi um he's covering
the NFL for the mothership for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]